it's so crunchy she looks like she's in
pain oh no i'm so sorry
you're shaving your face i just noticed
what you're doing
hello everyone today i'm doing a stream
that i'm very very very excited about
this is like
one of the most exciting things that i
think i've done on the year i think this
is gonna be a really good time
so what i'm doing is for tiltify this is
not sponsored it's just something that i
you know wanted to do because i've been
working with them it's basically called
clause my cause and what i'm doing
is partnering with them to basically go
to smaller streamers who are currently
doing fundraising campaigns
going to their twitches and then just
like throwing money
on their campaigns so all of this is
money for charity not to the individual
streamers they have to be
someone who is currently uh streaming on
twitch using
these two hashtags is how we find them
basically so yes uh i feel like i need
to disclose this is not my money
i ain't got this kind of money um this
is
tiltify ultimately uh helping me give to
people and i am part of the tiltify
clause team hopefully we get some
like really excited uh reactions
um is the plan so this dude if i make
myself smaller toontown gives to you a
lot
awaited update just for you has
currently raised
358 dollars for the past year of his 2
500 goal all right um
let's do it what's that shall we drop
some money on him
let's go let's do it um let's do it
[Music]
what
oh my gosh
[Music]
this is so good holy crap
pierce is watching my stream hi um
i don't know what to say to to that
oh my gosh oh my goodness
oh man that really puts a smile on my
face
and now we're almost at our goal we're
now less than 150
away from like having to play a horror
game and i hate horror games oh no i
have to make him play a horror game oh
that's my bad we're streaming horror
games
i'm so sorry we just dropped 500 on them
you've got to wait for it to notice
though come on
come on you'll see it any second now but
i will continue to watch you play ari in
the meantime for the record
this one was 100 goal that we have just
dropped
500 on wait hold on
i'm gonna i'm crying cool
this is absolutely incredible i know i'm
crying because she's so sweet
doing my absolute best oh my gosh stop
crying but that's not
that's not gonna happen um
and we have my first ever hype train
happening
oh i have honestly no idea how i hate
crane works
i don't need that to be fair i don't
need this to be fair i have no idea
i think we've sent it there we go
where the [ __ ] are you guys are they
those just literally just haunting me
we donated a thousand dollars oh stop
stuff is happening my chat i don't know
what it is because i don't
i don't want to die
[Laughter]
i got a raid oh [ __ ] okay well
hang on guys what's happening your
donations hit over a thousand
what hold on i don't even care if near
i don't even care if i die at this point
what is happening
what happened this one's cool because
it's like multiple people what's
happening
look whoever is rating me right now
thank you so much who is this
and i like how they just saw this dead
body with the report button the whole
time as well
[Laughter]
i love that it's like all of the friends
oh this is this is something
this is something right here whoever
this raid is thank you for the raid
oh my a lot
dude oh my
no god his head and she's so cute
gonna be giving love like that seriously
are you kidding me oh my god
[Music]
it went through what
uh-huh
okay okay okay let me let me drop you
guys here we go here we go here we go
she hasn't said anything
lana peace and did i see your name it's
just like all the notifications god
thank you so much
she just really good eyeliner how'd she
do that though oh my god
you just came down the door
thank you so i'm gonna cry thank you so
much seriously all the hugs the course
there we go nobody she didn't know right
you guys all came in here and yelled
about tom what happened
hello
what what just happened did something
happen i'm confused
hello okay okay
she's just trying to build a desk you
know just out here trying to build her
desk
i'm sorry for the alert it's me singing
i'm just kidding it's brilliant don't
get rid of it
i like it thank you guys it's so good
donations
thank you alana pierce my dear for the
1290
donation and jugs for the 25
anonymous for the 1jtv for the 20 and
dustin
for the ten dollars
oh my god i can't even speak right now
thank you so much
um so i'm going to mute my alerts real
quick and then i want to talk about why
i chose this charity yeah because this
is a cherry that's very close to me
that sounds great i love that over 10
times as much
um so hope for the day is a
charity that's um doing uh
active suicide prevention
and um
[Music]
i i've had a long history of mental
health
issues and um in 2017 i even
had a suicide attempt um
but right now i'm feeling
so much better um and i wanted to do
what um what i could
to try and help this charity um
[Music]
which um is doing something that i
really believe in
i just made myself sad so yeah um
i i chose this charity because of those
reasons
suicide has this is the smallest dreamer
a part of my life no matter how much i
don't want it to be part of my life
trying to raise money
i don't want anyone awareness or suicide
prevention
i don't think you had any any money
raised because
um people can be really nice issues
there we go there it is [ __ ] what
[Laughter]
elana pierce what the [ __ ] that's what
we're here for
why didn't a notification go off for
that oh my god
a lot of peers
that's why because you all were
following so the notification didn't go
off
thank you so so much for that generous
donation i am losing my mind everybody
that's coming through there's too many
wonderful people in here to thank but
thank you guys so much
hi we just crushed oh my god
whoa wait
what is going on holy cow hold on let me
switch this over
holy crap they're all so cool
that is 10 000 meals you guys are insane
what what wait wait wait wait wait okay
i'm sorry
i like that he's doing this so he can't
see what's happening
what is happening what what is happening
hello
are you i think he's just seeing the
donations i think that's what's just
happened
madden beast 232 has joined the orchard
hello i'm not crying
are you kidding me oh my god thank you
oh my god hello
arcs3r0 has joined the orchard thank you
so much for that donation uh
oh my god undead underscore witcher has
joined the orchard
there's so much happening i'm i oh
wait it's definitely getting harder to
get to
so many people say wait when they notice
it it's so funny
do you guys see like this donation
there's a stream uh several months ago
where
somebody was trying to raise money and
twitch donated holy [ __ ]
oh my god
it has two thousand dollars eat a
scorpion and a tarantula
oh my god yeah i'm gonna eat a scorpion
i'm gonna eat a scorpion
and a tarantula and i'm gonna get pie a
pie to the face
so what what you guys just alana what
you just
what you just donated to was for the
association to benefit children
it is an amazing organization um that
helps kids
from like ages 5 all the way up to 21
and they help so many
they they help change so many lives so
thank you
thank you so much for that i am like
just in
in shock i'm scared okay wait
so the claw i just broke the claw
i feel like it's gonna come alive it's
so weird
okay this is the tail oh my god
i'm shaking right now i'm so sorry
oh it seems like it's huge
so this is the claw
how is that so crunchy excuse me
it's just like sticking out of my breath
it's not bad
it's so crunchy she looks like she's in
pain
oh no i'm so sorry would i eat this
regularly no
no wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
you can't do that did you see that wait
i could do that i could totally do that
[Music]
this what guys guys you got
no no no no no you guys can't do this to
me
don't do this to me right now
i think another that's red-nosed oh my
god maybe i don't know
come on there we go
they had two viewers anyways i had like
a hundred dollars that's my
reward now so let's follow come on you
guys we're following
do you follow him back up the path are
they playing pokemon go he lets you guys
go through first and then he
only have one viewer and it's b yeah
we're [ __ ] hella rich
you don't got no fighting dragons around
here we interrupt this pre-recorded
episode
oh it's pre-recorded that makes sense
oh my god holy
mother of oh my god yeah i have to i
have to shave my beard
i have to shave my beard yeah you do
do does everybody want me to do it now i
just literally do it right yes
yes yes he's not even hesitating these
people
are just so brave this would happen i
was not prepared
i'm putting on way too much shaving
cream but whatever oh i have too much
hair i should have
that is going to be tough i should have
taken a bit to it for um
electric razor to it yeah you're going
to have a tough time i'm just
that's a lot of here we go it's going to
take you a while i need to partner in
this endeavor
because anthony has to shave too i'm
pretty sure ride or die and he's going
to flip
he has to shave as well anthony anthony
i need you to get on twitch
right the [ __ ] now okay hold on
go on our stream and see what happened i
had to interrupt
the pre-recorded pokemon episode
why why is the number 341
the the number is 341
[Laughter]
alana pierce donated two thousand
dollars
what it just happened oh my god
sitting here talking to brittany
just on the phone and then all of a
sudden i see
i see the number go from 105
to 2105 and i go
i think i'm going to cry right now 500
for this
um
and we don't really have an audience and
all of a sudden
um this happened and is more than twice
you're shaving your face i just
get on zoom and i will get you on there
and we'll do this right now okay
this is incredible here we are excited
i'm so excited it looks like
he'll look like he went back to like
middle school come on chris it's all
over his carpet
no you're already doing a good job come
on for someone who is using a webcam to
see
that's true dude watch be careful
anthony just
just shaving it like a boss anthony
i'm so concerned hey
[Music]
there you go there you go ah you can't
see it
i just skipped it 20 subs
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh the absolute best she's so cute
i don't understand why but it's so weird
i spilled water all over myself